before I even knew that visual effects
existed I wanted to be a pyro technician
that was my quest that's what got me
into visual effects because I love
explosions it's probably because I watch
too much Power Rangers but I loved movie
explosions whether it's Jabba the Hutt's
barge exploding or Independence Day
which just blew my mind man in the
Empire State Building went up
film explosions they're so beautiful
they're so chaotic and they're so unique
there's such an art form to it but these
days
it's just not hidden it's probably
because there's so many explosions done
in CGI and there's so many common
mistakes and misunderstandings and CGI
explosions that they're just not
capturing the beauty of the real thing
in this video we're going to team up
with Jordan Allen our resident
simulations expert and we're going to
learn why CGI explosions fall short and
what it takes to make them awesome
all right so let's take a look at CGI
explosions versus the real thing and I'm
going to kick things off with the
Nicholas Cage film from 2009 and this is
right at the beginning of the era of
when we can start simulating the smoke
and fire of explosions it's cool
but it's pretty wonky looking yeah
dude
so if you look it's fire from the get-go
the fire just comes out of the plane and
you get this very smooth round ball of
fire and then what's really interesting
here is as it burns out the whole thing
changes colors at the same time so you
don't have like red and yellow down here
it's all at the same color and then it
all fades out and you actually end up
with a really odd effect of there being
like brown smoke yeah it's the brown
smoke explosion and Fire gets dim it
doesn't get brown it goes basically
white to Yellow it's like a hint of
orange but it also merely goes to Red
because as Fire gets dimmer it becomes
more saturated which is really tricky to
do when it comes to compositing and like
image manipulation it's definitely an
old school approach to shading
explosions the fire is sitting on top
like this fake glow that's just kind of
like layered on another really
interesting thing about this explosion
so this plane just came flying in going
how fast planes usually go it's just
over 100 miles an hour when it hits all
that inertia should be in the fuel I
think it's splattered but this explosion
goes straight up yeah and that's a lot
of why you just see a big round ball
here is because they just went pressure
in heat yeah it just Rises straight up
when a plane actually crashes with fuel
it doesn't crash and the fuel goes up it
crashes and it goes yep it's inheriting
the velocity of what is exploding too
right if you jump out of a car right
yeah you're not just standing still yeah
and like land on the ground and go all
right you're going to be going however
fast the car is going right out the gate
and yes air resistance will slow you
down and create other interesting
patterns so I figured what's contrast
this with another airplane explosion a
real airplane explosion from the movie
Speed
oh look at the oh oh man it just makes
you feel things I mean you are getting
that same like mushrooming effect but
all the diversity of nature are driven
through looking closely at this we see a
huge demonstration of one of the key
missing things from CGI explosions not
to say oh they're all missing it but a
lot of them are fuel look at all this
fuel yes dude I was gonna point to that
too the way a Hollywood explosion works
is this so your power technician takes
what they call a lifter it's basically
an explosive that's going to push things
into the air now gasoline doesn't
explode when it's lit on fire if you've
ever lit a puddle of gasoline on fire
which if you're 14 you probably have
you've probably noticed that just burns
on the surface you only get these
explosive Fireballs when you have a
mixture of gas and air in a lot of
surface area AKA a lot of droplets so
when that explosive goes off under that
gasoline it throws all these droplets of
gas into the air and then when that's
ignited by the leftover Embers and
Sparks and heat from that explosive you
get ignition and then a giant Fireball
so like when they blow up the front of
this airplane they have you know lifters
effectively cannons shooting out the
what's probably gasoline out the front
of the airplane here you get this big
white cloud of liquid and then watch how
it ignites oh yes dude and look at all
the wacky shape you get out of that
right because you did a water spray and
the water went through the air and then
all this crazy stuff and then it burns
and it's not that a unit of flame moved
through it or a unit of flame expanded
it all just ignited it all ignited so if
the fire caught up to the already
ejected gasoline there's another thing
that happens in real explosions like
this that misses from every film like no
one has done it I've never seen it
happen and it's the pressure
differential and they set off explosives
yes so I agree you know you set off into
a lifter and boom you get your first
Fireball but of course you got multiple
stages right so you snap another one
when that pressure shocked away from
that explosive explosive travels through
the fire you see a color shift and watch
it happen here this will go off here
you'll see an explosive boom and
except right there yeah
oh yeah it just rips gives it new life
yeah it's like a electric like heartbeat
going through the thing yeah the whole
explosion turns bright yellow and dims
down again it's a beautiful explosion
it's pretty incredible and then look at
the difference in color across the thing
too there's a lot of things that you
have to figure out to get a CG explosion
looking good yes but the one thing that
90 of movies seem to skip is just the
simple stage of having feelings
[Music]
oh yeah no fuel whatsoever
yeah you know CG explosions just like
real life explosion should have multiple
stages the initial expansion or ejection
of the gas followed by the Flames
igniting it not just the flames right
away so this especially if you look when
the fire spawns it's already fire what
is that fire burning where did it come
from who knows the fire just
spontaneously existed and like it looks
beautiful when it's in the later stages
but it's not being birthed how a real
explosion is birthed so the big
challenge with CG explosions is that we
have to make this thing completely from
scratch completely separated from The
Real World at its core an explosion is
comprised of volumes volumes you can
almost imagine is just like a 3D Cloud a
big dense fog that is comprised of
voxels voxels are essentially 3D pixels
if you think of a 2D pixel as something
that contains color information that
when viewed from far away will comprise
an image so too will these 3D pixels
work together in this volume to create
our smoke and our fire and our pressure
those core three aspects have a very
basic explosion similar Nation look to
mimic what you might expect from those
properties in real life this is a
beautiful looking explosion but this is
a perfect example of something that like
just doesn't have the soul of a real
explosion yeah like it had it's got the
look it's like a really well done
cartoon of explosion right that's fair
and that's like that's it you can't have
badass cartoon explosions I mean Akira
has sick cartoon explosions right yeah I
agree and if you look at the explosions
in anime actually I think they capture
more of the essence of what makes real
explosions exciting that a lot of Siege
explosions that we see in large
Hollywood films it feels like they've
nailed timing the steps of an explosion
the anticipation the initial
big movement and the slow down where
everything just ah so if you feel like
you feel the big expansion right away
yeah it just feels so Dynamic and it's a
great reference for feeling the
explosion because at the end of the day
what's the point of doing the explosion
if you're not feeling the impact of that
explosion yeah it's like what is that
gives an explosion impact look at
animation they'll answer your question
yeah
those born of mandalus this is from book
of Boba Fett Star Wars gets a lot right
but they get some stuff wrong this this
is an explosion example using what I
believe is the old shading method of
volumes right and what Jordan's
referring to here is the inaccurate
shading that we see in the explosion
here from knowing boom you've got the
big impact
yeah yeah it just feels like it's white
fire again yeah the inside isn't hot the
outside is hot so a real explosion as
the fire goes out it cools from the
outside in so the outside starts to cool
becomes black smoke but the inside is
still hot eventually you have like deep
red on the inside then all black smoke
on the outside you're missing all that
interaction of fire and smoke in the
belly it's just pitch black fire stuck
on top it's like you look the hot spots
I hear and the tips the explosion the
hot spots should be inside of it if you
look at an actual nuke going off you
have this hot Fireball and then outside
is just a smoke rolling off of it as the
outside cools yeah the initial shock
wave is really cool it's Dynamic it's
interesting but the shape it's a single
Source shape yeah which you may get with
a nuke right yeah but you wouldn't get
with smaller bombs and it's moving at
the speed of a smaller bomb but in the
shape of a nuke it's confusing for the
scale the animation but but the shading
in particular is what sets this aside
yeah you don't think explosions are
important you ever heard of The Big Bang
Yeah that's right we came from an
explosion you know it also came out of
the Big Bang technically Squarespace
today's sponsor
Squarespace is a service that helps you
build a website with their award-winning
templates they will get you what you
need to communicate with an audience
online like let's say you want to create
a website where you're going to sell
exclusive premium explosion footage
actually let's say you want to have a
subscription service well you know what
Squarespace offers gated membership
areas if you wanted to actually have a
whole membership thing going on kind of
like we do with our site
quarterdigital.com and you know let's
say you just have a perfectly curated
playlist of beautiful explosions that's
over on YouTube or Vimeo well you can
actually embed videos easily into your
web page designs on Squarespace you know
what you want to do some traffic
overviews see which explosions are hot
see which explosions are not same thing
you got all the analytical tools that
you might possibly need because
Squarespace has all that good stuff and
you know what you got somebody who's
writing blog posts about explosions but
you don't want to give them full admin
access to your website well they got you
covered there too you can have levels of
contributors it's really really useful
stuff when you have a whole team working
together so yeah if you're in the market
for a web page you want to get a domain
name got to build a store you want to
have some membership areas doesn't
matter Squarespace has it covered and
you know what we've heard before if you
want to jump in with a free trial head
on over to squarespace.com and if you
want 10 off your first purchase a
website or domain go to squarespace.com
Corridor crew because we got you hooked
up all right let's get back to talk
explosions
oh so many cauliflowers yeah look at all
these little guys
what's expanding what's burning the only
way fire can roll at you like this is
when you're actually below it and it
comes up which is how they did
Independence Day yeah to get those
firewalls rolling towards the camera
they had to put the camera above it and
shoot it up towards camera and just tilt
all the models on their side because
temperature rises you're right and the
really interesting thing is when you
look at those explosions all the fuel
that's burning is on the top of the
explosions because fire can only move in
the direction of things it's igniting
like you can have a really expansive
source that doesn't necessarily make the
fire just go out really far outside of
the fact that it throws the fuel out
right so if you want a fireball to like
rip forwards the fuel needs to be
leading it and Backdraft has a perfect
example of this
yourself
[Music]
so all this fuel look at all this fuel
the fire finally Burns through it
and expands forwards and over everything
like this is what Fire coming out the
camera should look like it should be
Fuel and you're like oh that doesn't
look too intimidating and then through
the fuel comes this angry violent
explosion that's what it should look
like
totally these little things dude oh yeah
all these things like Sparks and Embers
and like little flicks of flame yeah
it's so impactful it just feels so
organic it's like oh do I have to go
through and build an entire simulation
system to put that into my explosion I
want to look right in CG it's like yes
yeah I guess you do so another thing
that we see here is like all these
dresses hanging on racks when explosions
go off all the dresses going and they
like they flip in the wind and even if
the explosion's not touching it you see
that pressure wave move through which is
once again the essence of an explosion
right it's pressure it's expansion it's
a shock wave of all kind of stuff that's
so Advanced that I think we're just
barely getting into physics systems now
that can do that yeah you're right if
you're talking about combining all those
things into one simulation but that's
not how it's normally done it's weight
easier if each type of simulation is
self-contained because when the director
or producers send down notes of you know
we need to or direct this we need to
change this change this change this that
changing one thing won't now change six
other things or 600 other things like
you would if it's all in one cohesive
system which is a big reason why people
don't do it that way so Nico I think one
big problem here is that there are many
scenarios in modern films where
practical explosions simply wouldn't be
possible and you know the reason we go
to CG is for the benefits that it
provides right it makes the impossible
possible I actually have a sequence here
from Rogue one that I think is a perfect
example of this you can't you can't blow
up a planet in real life at least not
yet what does a planet look like when it
blows up there's no reference imagery
for this yeah so a lot of artistry a lot
of art Direction comes in and so this is
where we see how far we've come in
actually taking it all the way in CG
there's that initial moment but the
speed of explosions is so fast
it ignites so quick it's like it should
feel impactful and massive you're not
going to do this practically no way yeah
there's no way no way this is something
that doesn't exist we've seen nukes
explode yeah but this is I mean this
reminds me a lot of like the Tsar Bomba
footage the biggest nuke they were set
off in Russia but yeah you're right like
this is a perfect example of when you
need to do a CGI explosion and the CGI
explosion is better than any real
alternative like yeah
so the first thing that stands out to me
in the shot is they have dark stuff on
top of the fire it doesn't start as a
white firewall now actually to be fair a
nuclear bomb does start as a white
Fireball and I know they're emulating a
nuclear bomb but they're also pulling in
a little bit of like Hollywood special
effects explosion right and so you get
the impression that there's stuff on top
of the actual expanding Fireball now
because they have what looks like fuel
it's probably just smoke it looks like
fuel on top of a fireball man the glow
that's being cast how it's how it's
pushing through this smoke you see the
dust kick up you see the shock wave push
through you see the different layers and
elements all put together in a beautiful
way and this is a very important part of
the entire post process right you can
have the best Sim in the world it can be
totally dialed in but if every
Department isn't also meeting that
standard it will fall short a good
explosion can be destroyed in color it
can be destroyed especially in the
composite the compositing is a huge step
in getting a good explosion the reality
is when these artists are done with
these amazing explosions they don't look
anything close to this in their computer
they're outputting something that is
much Tamer than what the final composite
will do this is it without any of the
compositing wow this is just the
explosion we don't have the secondary
simulation of the Rings we have none of
the Dust kick up we have none of the
glow we have none of the lens elements
this is what it looks like and you look
at this and you go yeah it's a super
dope Sim but it looks like yeah CG
render it looks like a CG render and
this is again not super high resolution
and you can get away with that when the
compositing is there because that is
what will cement your shot and make it
feel way more realistic that's pure
Artistry that's now in the mix and that
is something that you don't have to
concern yourself with when when you're
doing special effects explosions right
you don't have to worry about well how
hot should that glow be because when as
a visual effects artist when you're done
with your sim you are turning over not
just the finished flat explosion you're
turning over all the passes that make up
that explosion you're turning over the
emission isolated naked and alone the
the density the smoke right every single
thing that goes into it the comp artist
can take extra correct remove entirely
or used to further enhance the image
they have total control over that
process so Nico I know you're in the
camp that sfx explosions will never be
replaced they just can't be matched in
CG and I feel you on that but I want to
encourage you that we are headed in the
right direction
I'll be the judge of that you know that
yeah that's what I want I want you to be
the gentleman do me a favor and close
your eyes okay
so go ahead and look at this
that looks like a completely real
explosion it looks photo real doesn't it
yeah this is made from Urban brodesco he
is a very talented artist and he using
the Pyro big volume which is a
relatively new feature in Houdini shaded
this to look literally borderline photo
where it looks fantastic when you're
talking about beautiful big detailed
crispy explosions this this is super
encouraging it's a couple things I
noticed Emily notice that it's the
inside is hot the outside is cool right
like this stuff's outside it's cold and
then as you get inside the explosion
it's getting hot yeah I've noticing the
glow from the inside like you don't get
brown smoke you get fires turning red
and the smoke is lit by that light yeah
that looks beautiful yeah so so I mean
this is again this is something that
just became possible not too long ago I
mean I feel like ilm's been able to do
this for quite a while like uh
undercover of night but like us folk you
know people working from home and that's
that is what is so exciting about this
like this new Evolution in explosions
allows someone with enough education and
how to develop up these explosions to do
AAA title explosions from home that's so
cool as long as the Artistry is there
behind it the tools are closer than
they've ever been to make it all very
possible to do this in most pipelines
we're getting to the point now where I'm
optimistic that one day I will walk into
a movie I will see a CG explosion and I
will not know that it is CG and that's
when I know what made it so my first
love in cinema was explosions and it's
changed so much over the years I've been
wanting to see the real thing make a
Resurgence hopefully with this video we
can give some more appreciation and
respect for real explosions and good CG
explosions out there yeah and who knows
maybe into the future here we'll see
some more quality CGI explosions and
some more bangers of the real thing in
cinema fingers crossed fingers crossed
fingers crossed
I hope you guys learned something from
this video or at least just enjoyed the
process of watching us kind of dive into
a complex topic like explosions if you
want us to do more deep Dives let us
know in the comments we have a blast
doing it so we're super down for that in
the meantime though tomorrow morning I'm
still watching Netflix we are dropping
our final episode of punch for punch
where we take a deep dive into the
action in The Witcher we actually do our
own little short film too so it's uh
it's worth a watch and again that is
coming out tomorrow morning so check it
out and of course subscribe